i'll just like slide people's dm
sometimes like yo
who is the last person's dms that you've
slid into
oh i don't know if i could say it's kind
of like that's tea like my fans would go
crazy
that's what you have to tell us
[Music]
it just came out what july 17th
yeah kind of talk about what it was like
to put out that
song and i feel like you kind of get a
little bit personal and candid about
your own insecurities and what's going
on in your life
so what really inspired the lyrics of
this song
um it was it was really just like a so i
have a little studio in my room
back in north carolina because that's
where i'm from and um
i i just i was sitting there and i
really did want to write something like
a little more lyrical and a little more
like deeper on like how i feel and stuff
that i deal with
and stuff uh so i just started like i
started writing it i started just
writing the song right there in my room
uh and then i yeah it's really just
inspired by like
habits that that i have that i hate that
i've still to deal with what was that
like to sort of take a look
inside and a look in the mirror if you
will and put those thoughts
on paper was that hard or um obviously
like
it was a little difficult because like
you know when you're writing like
i try and like relive emotion you know
what i mean just to get the best
explanation that i can of how i'm
feeling uh so obviously it's just like
going back through those
those those times and like those
yeah those times of just uh all that
stuff so it yeah definitely was a little
a little hard but it gave the song
emotion you know what i mean it gave her
that feeling
what really i mean does inspire is it
all like love
is it breakups what what really triggers
i love writing about like heartbreak
stuff like that that's
like girls that's my favorite thing to
write about um but
you know uh i mean it's really just
whatever i get inspired
super easily and like i'll just be like
driving and it'll just hit my head
i have a little melody so yeah it's
really anything i should be inspired by
yeah i mean this song is a follow-up to
love letter which i freaking love
it's so good
[Music]
what does it feel like to put so much
vulnerability
into your songs and have you ever gotten
a call from an ex that you wrote a song
about
where they were like oh this is about me
um
so with the vulnerability yeah it's i
like it like i like putting
more being more vulnerable in my songs
you know just because like then i'll get
those people that that are going through
the same thing i am that that can relate
to my music
and like actually listen to it with a
purpose you know and uh that's really
cool to me
but um yeah i've never i've never gotten
a call from like an ex
that i've wrote a song about i've
written a song about uh
and i i've been scared of it
yeah i've i've uh i've definitely been
like not scared of it but a little like
a little worried about it
in the back of my head but it hasn't
happened yet how you telling me you love
me then you take it back
what's love can you tell me that if i
gave you the world would
you do ask the question uh what is love
in that song
so what do you think love is or what is
love to you at this point
in your life so i'm actually i'm kind of
at a point in my life right now
where i'm really like focusing on myself
and not trying to like
get into like other things um so i don't
i don't actually know i haven't really
been
like thinking about stuff like that um
but like i don't know i just
i want somebody that's going to support
me all the time and
just natural connection like i really
love connections and
just vibing with people so i guess
that's love to me you know yeah
oh that's a good answer so worldly um
you are only 16 for a few more days so
how will you celebrate the big
big one seven i'm just going in the
studio that's that's all i'm doing for
uh
yeah so that's it yeah i'm not i'm not
i'm not like a i'm not like a big
party person especially right now like
with everything going on like
partying is definitely not the way to go
so uh
i just want to relax chill in the studio
make something like i want to go in the
studio
for like uh like with no like plan you
know what i mean just go in there and
have fun like not like
we're gonna work this song today and
stuff like that just kind of create
something
i love that you said that you're not
into like the whole
partying thing that you're trying to
take what's going on right now super
seriously i literally just saw an email
come through about a bunch of tick
talkers
getting together at the hype house and
having a massive party
what do you have any feelings on that i
mean
i was invited to it i was gonna go and i
was not i was not gonna go but i was
like
invited to it um but i'm just i mean
me personally just not not the move
right now
um so yeah i can't speak for anybody
else but
yeah that's just not not the not the
move right now i think you made
a wise decision and i appreciate
um how seriously you're taking all of
this are you you said that you're
working on music so are we gonna get
that full album a full ep what's going
on you know
there there might be an ep soon ish
in the in the next like near couple
months maybe
uh it's it's been uh it's been a uh or
like a little bit more than a couple
months but
like hopefully down the road uh
there's been there's been some like talk
about it and some discussions so
yeah hopefully
i feel like you posted a cover of love
yourself
are you inspired at all let's put it
this way are you inspired by
justin bieber's career at all um
obviously yeah
uh i it's not like i'm not trying to
follow the footsteps of justin um but
definitely
yeah i mean i feel like justin bieber is
an inspiration to everybody that makes
music he's an incredible musician i i
definitely am a little inspired by him
but not like too
too crazy have you met him or talked to
him or has he
dm'd you at all no no no no
we need to make that happen i know yeah
hopefully one day
when when you think about your career
and kind of getting to that next
level what does that look like to you
and
does it make you excited nervous when
you think about
you know stardom and hollywood and i
mean
not really nervous music's something
i've wanted to do for a long time
and like just just the fact that that i
even am
getting to do it right now is is amazing
so um
i'm excited for where it's going to take
me really excited wherever it's going to
take me i'm excited
so yeah i'm just ready
[Music]
we have to talk about tick-tock yes i
mean you have
so many freaking followers on there do
you feel like
tick tock really sort of amplified where
things are for you or do you feel like
the music was
like how did tick tock help i mean tick
tock of course it helped
i mean yeah they it definitely helped me
push and be like
obviously my my fan base is very
supportive um
so it's it it works out but um
yeah i definitely was like hey because
i've been doing music for a while in the
background
so i was like hey like you know let's uh
you know start doing this promoting it
publicly and so um
yeah i just started promoting it on tick
tock and stuff like that and it
definitely helped
there does seem to be quite uh
i want to say obsession with couples on
tick tock i'm sure you are
very aware of this um but with that
always comes like
drama so what do you make of all of all
of that and why do you think people are
so interested in it
i don't i honestly couldn't tell you i
have no idea why people are so
interested in it like obviously it's
like
it's kind of it's not like fun but it's
like interesting when like something
happens it's like whoa like i gotta know
so i feel like that that definitely
plays into it like they're always trying
to figure out what's going on and what
happened
uh but yeah i mean it's even fun for me
i love whenever like
stuff pops up i'll just be like oh
what's going on now
like who are you interested in um
i don't know there's there's been all
this there's been all this tea recently
with all the houses and everything
that's that's definitely been not fun to
watch but it's been like
because those are those are still my
friends and stuff but like
it's been it's been interesting but yeah
i just i don't i choose not to get
involved with it so
is the hype house trying to recruit you
is that why you got invited to that
party
oh no no no okay yeah no
you're just like your friend yeah yeah
yeah i've known case forever so
is i know you said you're focused on
yourself right now but is there
uh perhaps a female tick talker that you
have a crush on or that you want to
admit that you would be
potentially interested in one day
um yeah there definitely is i mean
there there there is like i always like
scrolling through
and
uh sometimes sometimes i get left on red
like on god i get left on red all the
time
[Music]
you on red come on i don't know it's
just it's
they they get it like they're like ah
he's just sliding in my dreams
so who who is the last person's dms that
you've slid into
oh i don't know if i could say it's kind
of like that's tea like my fans would go
crazy
that's what you have to tell us
uh she's a smaller account that's that's
all i'm gonna
do do fans have an idea that maybe
there's something going on
no no okay and that's like that's like
how i'm trying to like keep it
okay so dm's on the deal
yeah exactly that's a good that's
exciting
yeah all right yeah yeah yeah all right
that's fair i respect it
a lot of your tick tocks though are you
playing guitar and i feel like you're
pretty freaking good at guitar
how did you learn to play guitar i
actually
i taught myself when i was 10 how to
play
so yeah yeah i've been playing i got an
electric guitar for christmas
i taught myself like a bunch of
metallica songs stuff like that
so uh yeah and i just kept with it i
started playing acoustic guitar more
and like yeah then justin bieber like
that whole cover
wait wait you were 10 years old and
listening to metallica
i was yeah that's insane what did your
parents think
i actually started listening to it
because of my step-dad he was uh yeah he
was
he was the one who like would always
play in the car and stuff and i just got
into it
as your star continues to grow like what
do you want people to know about you
that we might not know just from work
from your tick tocks or looking at your
your instagram i'm just a simple person
i just
i like my little simple things i make my
music and uh
yeah that's not much to me i just
it's what i'm doing right now and uh
yeah do you at all feel pressure to be a
good
role model given your platform oh of
course
yeah um there's you know you got you got
a lot of
younger people especially my audience is
definitely a little younger
so you always got to be you know kind of
watching out for what i'm doing and
stuff like that and
just be wary of what i'm posting and
stuff
and make sure that i'm not like
influencing people
though yeah yeah
what's like the ultimate goal for you i
mean do you want to focus 100
on music is acting something that you
want to do
kind of paint me that that picture of
the future um
definitely for the future for my future
i'm looking at
more music 100 uh not really i'm not
really too big into like
trying to act and stuff like that like
it's not really my my thing right now
so definitely trying to take music as
far as i can
so and then do you have a message to
your fans right now with everything
going on
and with your upcoming projects stay
inside
stay safe please wear a mask please wear
a mask
um and yeah i got new music coming so
be on be on the ready for that it's it's
good and
new music videos coming so be on the
ready for it really excited
when is the habits music video gonna
drop a couple weeks tops yeah